MORE.
>> Tucker: BARS.
SO IF YOU ARE A REGULAR VIEWER
OF THE SHOW, YOU HAVE NOTICED
THERE'S BEEN SOMETHING MISSING
FOR THE PAST COUPLE OF MONTHS.
PROBABLY ARE A FAVORITE GUEST,
MARK STEIN, HAS NOT BEEN ON THIS
PROGRAM.
WE HAD TO SEND LIAM NEESON OUT
TO TRACK HIM DOWN AND RETURN HIM
BUT MARK STEIN IS BACK WITH US
TONIGHT AND WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR
WELCOME BACK, MARK.
>> HIGH, GREAT TO BE BACK.
YET, IT LIAM NEESON RESCUED ME
FROM A BUNCH OF ALBANIANS WHO
HAVE BEEN HOLDING ME.
IT'S TAKEN 12 COMING TO THE
MULTIPLEX NEAR YOU ANYTIME SOON.
>> Tucker: I WILL BE FIRST IN
LINE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
THE DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS OF
AMERICA SEEM LIKE THEY HAVE BEEN
TAKEN OVER BY A BUNCH OF TRUMPED
OF GUARDIANS FROM BROOKLYN.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S WHAT HAS
HAPPENED?
>> YEAH, SOMETIMES YOU SEE MASS
MOVEMENTS THAT ACTUALLY DWINDLE
INTO NICHE MARKETS.
IT HAPPENS A LOT ON BROADWAY,
FOR EXAMPLE.
IT USED TO BE THE MAINSTREAM OF
AMERICAN POPULAR CULTURE AND
THEN BECAME A LITTLE BOUTIQUE
THING.
SAME THING HAPPEN WITH JAZZ AND
THESE GUYS HAVE GONE THE SAME
WAY AND IN FACT, THEY ARE USING
THE SAME CHOREOGRAPHY.
THOSE JAZZ HANDS.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
PLOTTING --
YOU'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT REAL
PROBLEMS WITH MEN IN AMERICA.
WE ARE NOW WATCHING A POLITICAL
CONVENTION WHERE CLAPPING IS SO
TRIGGERING, EVERYBODY HAS TO
MAKE JAZZ HANDS LIKE CAMP
ASSISTANT CHOREOGRAPHER'S
RESEARCH REHEARSING SOME NUMBER
FROM HELLO DOLLY.
I FIND A JAZZ HANDS TRIGGERING
BECAUSE IT REMINDS ME OF OLD
TIME NANNY SINGERS SO IT'S LIKE
BEING AT A CONVENTION OF THE
VIRGINIA DEMOCRAT GOVERNOR AND
THE GOVERNOR AND ALL THE REST OF
THEM ALL DOING THEIR MANY SONGS.
IN THIS LIGHT IS THE JUDE
GENERATION, SOCIALISM
SLAUGHTERED MILLIONS.
IT LEAVES TRUST SAFARI ENDS CAN
SLAUGHTER ANYBODY.
THEY ARE NOT SERIOUS SO SUPER
SOCIALIST.
>> Tucker: WE HAVE REALLY
MISSED YOU.
I THINK IT'S A FAIR POINT AND
THAT'S WHY THIS IS WORTH TAKING
A LOOK AT, THEY DO HAS AN EFFECT
ON THE MAINSTREAM OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
I MEAN, THEY ARE USING LANGUAGE
THAT UNFORTUNATELY
ELIZABETH WARREN USES.
OR BETO AURORA, OR THAT A BOOKER
KID FROM NEW JERSEY.
THEY SEEM TO BE CRIBBING THEIR
NOTES FROM THE DSA.
>> YEAH, I THINK THAT'S WHAT
ANGELA GOT WRONG HERE NO ONE IS
INTERESTED IN, YOU KNOW, THE
CONTROLLING HEIGHTS OF THE
ECONOMY.
THIS NONSENSE IS ACTUALLY WHAT
THEY ARE ABOUT AND IF YOU LISTEN
TO THE DEMOCRAT DEBATE WHICH I
WATCHED FROM THOUSANDS OF MILES
AWAY SO IT SEEMED EVEN WEIRDER,
CORY BOOKER AT ONE TIME SAID WE
DON'T TALK ENOUGH ABOUT TRANS
AMERICANS AND IN PARTICULAR, WE
DON'T TALK ENOUGH ABOUT
AFRICAN-AMERICAN TRANS PEOPLE.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE I GET THIS
RIGHT.
AFRICAN-AMERICAN TRANS
AMERICANS.
AND OF COURSE, THE ANSWER TO
THAT IS THAT ON THESE TERMS, YOU
CAN NEVER TALK ENOUGH ABOUT
AFRICAN-AMERICAN TRANS
AMERICANS.
THIS OBSESSION WITH BOUTIQUE
DEMOCRATICS WHICH THEY TAKE AS
SERIOUSLY, IT'S BASICALLY LIKE
IT DOWNTOWN ABBEY FOR
PROGRESSIVES.
IF YOU GET TO SIT NEXT TO THE
YOUNGER DAUGHTER, THAT IS
ACTUALLY SMALL, I AM A WHITE
WOMAN OF PRIVILEGE SO I HAVE TO
SIT DOWN AT THE POINT FAR END OF
THE TABLE BECAUSE AN
AFRICAN-AMERICAN TRANS AMERICAN
NONVETERINARY PERSON GETS TO SIT
AT THE HEAD OF THE TABLE.
THEY TAKE IT ALL SERIOUSLY, THE
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES TAKE IT
ALL SERIOUSLY, IT'S AN
ALTERNATIVE REALITY THAT THEY
HAVE SUCCESSFULLY CREATED.
>> Tucker: IT IS BORING AS
HELL.
IF ONLY THEY WOULD SPEND
4 MINUTES TELLING US WHAT THEY
THINK OF THE FEDERAL RESERVE
BANK THAT I WOULD BE INTERESTED.